Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!!
This is going to be my Sherlock finale video.
If they did a great job of leading everything
together going back to season one just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet.
Because this is the last episode of Sherlock
probably for a long time I have some notes
at the end of this about what's coming next
and what the cast and crew of said.
So there is a new round of the Sherlock giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so that
you don't miss anything.
So there are just so many things to talk about
this in the top 10 format this should be 15,
so number 10 that really funny Mycroft whore
introduction is almost like he's in a dream
sequence.
You get the reveal that Sherlock just staged
it so that he become so afraid and reveal
the truth.
Sherlock has a sister the way they pull that
off is perfect like Mycroft's murder house
is he's watching this old pulp detective thriller,
it's funny to watch Mycroft express emotion
because supposedly he's not supposed to have
any like he makes a joke later in the episode
were shallots almost forced to kill Amaury
says you know I'm I might have a little hard
want you aim for that.
So the cats out of the bag Mycroft comes clean
in number nine is forced to go to Baker Street
for health just like any other client.
So he has to sit in the chair jump through
all the hoops of this all the comedy of that.
But then he explains euros's Backstory she's
one year older than Sherlock, but six years
younger than Mycroft see you get a little
more context for her character.
The funny thing about this is that Sharon
furred in the books.
The third mythical brother of the homes was
supposed to be the smartest of all like towering
above Mycroft himself so they did that in
this episode because it's euros, it's a sister,
it's a different name, so she has this titanic
genius that dwarfs the other homes brothers
she's been kept secret this whole time because
she's such a danger to herself to everyone
else.
So number eight the Sharon furred reveal like
I said it's the name of the mythical third
homes brother that wasn't written by Conan
Doyle, it's not really part of the canon,
which is the theoretical think it was at a
later to sort of sew up the logic of the used
it as the name for this Alcatraz prison that
she stuck in I should actually say that the
title of the episode is also an Easter egg
for the Conan Doyle story the adventure of
the final problem which was meant to be the
last Sherlock Holmes story he was going to
kill the character off.
But then fans revolted he brought him back
later.
But originally the final problem was sort
of like the Reichenbach fall where he went
out taking down Moriarty they use that, during
the Christmas special were he's in is mine
Palace at the Reichenbach fall.
So originally, that was meant to be the theoretical
death of the character in the books, but in
the episode.
They use it as a sort of an Easter egg for
Sherlock's obsession with Deepwater that goes
back to red beard.
So family Backstory number seven Musgrave
we learn about their ancestral home if you
saw the James Bond movie sky fall it's kind
of like that.
It just like this really old home had been
there family for a long time there were all
these fake graves out front that Sherlock
was obsessed with that his sister used as
the cipher for the east wind riddle that she
kept repeating, so she turned it into a song,
but the code for solving it was taken from
the graves that Sherlock like to play around
as a child when he was playing Pirates with
his friends number six the prison takeover.
So there's this big reveal that she's in this
Sharon furred prison the most impregnable
fortress for you lockup the worst of the worst
they set it up pretty hard-core, so no surprise
that the reveal event is that Hannibal lector
is actually running the prison, so it was
a great twist words like oh we all spent time
with her.
She all turned us.
So, were following her orders but the bigger
one number five is the Moriarty reveal where
you learn that Mycroft had been using her
genius to help stop future potential crimes,
but as a result was forced to give her things
in exchange one of them was the violin.
The other was five uninterrupted minutes with
Moriarty five years ago.
So there was this great introduction sequence
where they don't reveal to you that it's in
the past.
Moriarty gets off the helicopter to clean
just like a total boss just like it's so great
to be back to a little dance for the fans.
Everyone's going crazy then you learn that
it's five years ago and he's actually been
playing euros is great gain the great game
that Moriarty teased is actually her great
game that she set in motion to get Sherlock
to help save her.
So on route to this there's a whole bunch
of Easter eggs the case that she forces them
to solve the three Garrett it brothers is
actually named after the adventure of the
three care dubs which I actually think they
used as a Series III episode to, but she persons
of this emotional wringer, just sort of like
lab rats just seeing how they'll react how
their morality will adapt to the situation
like will you do something that you never
thought that you would do nice moment from
Mycroft that proves that he's not a total
psychopath.
He actually does have emotions tries to get
Sherlock to kill him, so that he won't have
to kill Watson but that she knocks them out
takes them back to their family home in Sherlock
learns the truth number four that there was
no red beard.
The dog.
It was actually his friend in that part of
the reason why Sherlock doesn't remember his
sister is because he rewrote his memories
because the trauma of losing his friend was
so bad.
That was the day that he started to push emotions
out and be the Sherlock that you met in the
first season, but number three as he saves
his sister helps bring her down, so to speak
her mind Palace where she was trapped up in
the air.
He also learns that he stronger because of
his emotions and he should welcome that.
So he's never going to be as smart as Mycroft
or euros, but he will always beat them because
he's a stronger person.
So not smarter, but stronger because he's
learned to not push his emotions away.
So you know his friendship with Watson help
teach them that you kinda see that play out
over the course of the episode the Molly Hooper
I love you moment also kinda plays into that
to, but number two you see Sherlock visiting
his sister later just showing you a more hopeful
ending that she's no longer alone.
There's as big reveal that she's beyond words.
She can't communicate she's not talking to
anyone but Sherlock can speak to her through
music.
So even if she isn't literally talking she
still communicating with them now to see the
family come visit Mycroft telling his parents
look she still alive so they eventually go
visit her.
So they imply that she gets well enough so
they can actually have a relationship with
her even if it still kind of weird she's locked
up for the rest of her life.
But number one is the message from Mary just
making you wonder.
You know Miss you your like oh my God, is
this can be some sort of Moriarty reveal is
just another final message from Mary giving
them a big called action explaining why what
they do as they solve crimes have these adventures
is so necessary for the people that need them
so she's just telling them that they need
to carry on.
They do this big montage were, there's a couple
more Easter eggs the Viking on the floor.
There is actually the musician Paul Weller
whose art like this big bank of the jam your
big musician big rock star that also happens
to be a friend of Martin Freeman, so that
sort of like a celebrity cameo the Rathbone
Place is an Easter egg for Basil Rathbone
who played the character in the 1939 film
series you see Rosie you see Molly Hooper,
so she's not really dead.
So, just sort of like a goodbye in a way for
them to show you that there still having adventures
regardless of whether or not they're going
to be more Sherlock episodes, so I know a
lot of you are asking the cast and crew has
said that they want to do more Sherlock episodes
but if they do is going to be like another
two years at least before their more so if
they decide to do more.
It is going to be a long time but will probably
hear you know whether or not it's actually
going to happen relatively quickly.
The other really funny thing.
This is just like a small moment from the
first time he met euros is like a lingering
question I think you know, just to kind of
poke the fans little like you can wonder about
this poor not can answer for sure is one euro
says to Sherlock is he's playing the violin
you've had sex I can tell I've had sex in
for a minute.
You just kind of stop and say wait a minute
when Sherlock have sex with it was with Molly
Hooper for sure and I think that they answered
that he did not have sex with Janine.
So you wonder, it's like is Irene Adler I
thought that she was mostly into women maybe
she's bisexual.
So just a really funny tease for the fans
the you guys let me know like what was your
favorite moment from the episode in which
episode was your favorite so far, I definitely
think this is one of my favorites but I feel
like Series III was a little bit stronger,
so not to go back and rewatch these again.
But it was a great run this year episode two
and episode three definitely better than the
first episode but he didn't spot any other
Easter eggs that I didn't mention there's
probably a whole bunch.
Just let me know in the comments and I'll
say congratulations to this week Sherlock
giveaway winner on call a bond you and a $20
Amazon gift card be sure to private message
me on the back and my channel so I can get
your contact details what can happen is is
because game of thrones is still a ways away
in there's not a lot of Doctor Who happening
if you're big Sherlock ban you're looking
for like another series that's kind of in
the same vein, I recommend taboo which is
Tom Hardy's new miniseries that's on FX networks
in the United States.
I think it's on sky in the UK, but the other
new series that him and to be doing videos
for is called Legion which is like an X-Men
TV show about the most powerful mutant, but
it's kind of like X-Men Breaking Bad it's
going to be carried on Fox's international
channels.
So whichever channel you watched The Walking
Dead on that's the channel that legion is
going to be on it's a Thursday show I'll be
doing a trailer video in the next couple of
days will explain what's going on with that
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for all my Sherlock videos and
you can click here for my latest game of thrones
video.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!